are you frustrated by the federal
government are you in touch with Trump
every single day I don't every single
day but I do talk to him when I need to
talk to him which is at least several
times a week and for those people who
don't know the backdrop here
there's been no governor in the nation
who's fought as much with Trump as I
have and that's okay we're both New
Yorkers we speak our mind and if we have
to disagree with disagree but during
this I said from the get-go this is not
about politics it's not about
personalities we have to be better than
that
for the jobs we do and I put my hand out
in partnership to work with you and
we'll call it straight and if you do the
right thing by New York I'll say it and
if you don't I'll say it and that's the
plain truth in this situation and since
then Howard he has been good in
delivering for New York he is he has he
is delivered for New York the Army Corps
of Engineers we built thousands of beds
he sent the Navy ship comfort to New
York he has delivered for New York right
so in other words it seems to be a
genuine working relationship where
things are working out which comforts me
I guess it's not perfect you know it's a
what relationship is perfect and look
there are incidents even during this
where he is taking shots at me and I
have taken shots at him not gratuitous
shots but by and large of his work don't
you think now I don't know this for a
fact but do you think he's happy a
brother got coronavirus because he works
for CNN and he's been critical of Trump
do you think that he you know like like
there's an enemies list or something
like that
he has a confrontational relationship
with my brother that is what it is I do
not believe I I'll say this he the
president always makes a point of saying
to me how is Chris is he doing okay and
that's not in his usual character you
know we're not chatty when we're on the
phone but he always makes the point to
say that about Chris and always remember
my mother so I don't think that I don't
think that I think part of it is genuine
personal feeling of anger and part of it
is also a little theater that goes with
politics especially the way it's
happening now and washing
you